en
france comme dans de nombreux pays
d'europe internet est partout et touche
toutes les générations près de
montpellier cette maison de retraite
vient d'inaugurer un cyber salon t ce
sont les jeunes qui guident dans
l'univers du web et les plus anciens et
les vernir françoise besson on va
commencer à travailler sur le pluc sur
les visages on lit leur incrédulité tout
autant que la concentration clic droit
ou gauche un nouvel univers ils ont
entre 70 et 90 ans et pour la première
fois délaissent leurs cannes pour
attraper la souris j'ai fait marcher la
souris alors je fais marcher la plus
fraîche et g20 guérir la maîtresse sa
maîtrise de la souris peut être mais là
pour guider leurs premiers pas sur
ordinateur des jeux pour enfants car
c'est en douceur est sur plusieurs mois
qu'ils vont acquérir la maîtrise de
l'outil épauler second départ de touche
un tuteur volontaire mais c'est sympa
parce que pour une fois c'est les plus
jeunes qui peuvent apprendre aux plus
âgés c'est intéressant comme échangeront
jeu par la prétention d'apprendre
et enfin avec de la passion et parce que
leur enregistré 100
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est d'attraper
des poissons demain ce sera d'envoyer
les courriers électroniques aux petits
enfants car l'ordinateur n'est qu'un
instrument pour maintenir un lien entre
générations les personnes d'abord
découvrent qu'elles ont encore des
capacités ça les stimule dans leurs
relations avec leurs familles plusieurs
m'ont dit je suis contente parce que mes
petits enfants sont fiers de moi et
cette fierté ça leur donne une estime 2
et 7 estime ben saleh maintient en
pleine forme
c'était un poisson volant
même éclat de rire un début de
complicité le cyber salon de thé de
cette maison de retraite est devenu pour
tous un rendez-vous précieux